[Music]
this announcement today
recognizes that empire actor jesse
smallett
took advantage of the pain and anger of
racism
to promote his career my concern is that
hate crimes would now
publicly be met with a level of
skepticism that previously didn't
didn't happen how can you doubt that
like how do you how do you not believe
that
it's the truth and then it became a
thing of like oh
it's not necessarily that you don't
believe that this is the truth
you don't even want to see the truth
to be quite honest
it's shameful angry chicago police
superintendent today
laying out the case they have against
jesse smallet
who is now charged with falsifying
this alleged hate crime planning a bogus
hate crime including mailing a letter
to himself as the assistant state
attorney laid out in intricate detail
when this first happened and his
explanation for it
everyone seemed to weigh in including
presidential candidates
cory booker and kamala harris both
called it a modern day lynching
in tweets just moments ago
senator harris released a statement
about this after being asked repeatedly
on the trail about it
like most of you i've seen the reports
about justice smallett and i'm sad
frustrated and disappointed
when anyone makes false claims to police
it not only
diverts resources away from serious
investigations but it makes it more
difficult for other victims of crime to
come forward
at the same time we must speak the truth
hate crimes are on the rise in america
part of the tragedy of this situation is
that it distracts from that truth
and has been seized by some who would
like to dismiss
and downplay the very real problems that
we must address
we should not allow that i will always
condemn racism and homophobia
we must always confront hate directly
and we must always seek
justice uh kamala harris there from the
trail let's bring in our panel
matthew connetty editor-in-chief of the
washington free beacon national security
analyst morgan ortegas
and jonathan swann national political
reporter for axios
pretty well worded jonathan in that in
that response
but a sticky issue for these candidates
who obviously went down
the road when this first came out right
the first statement was
you know passionate and righteous and
you know she was asked about it there
was a piece of video where she was asked
about it and
sort of had this strange moment where
she turned to her staff
looking quite irritated and then turned
back and clearly thought more about it
and put out the statement
there have been other politicians i
think nancy pelosi deleted her tweet
initially where she condemned this so
there was a whole lot of people who
initially condemned this who are now
in various ways trying to quietly walk
it back
morgan the police superintendent in
chicago i think
a lot of people were riveted by eddie
johnson here's another piece of it
how can an individual who's been
embraced by the city of chicago
turn around and slap everyone in this
city
in the face to make things worse the
accusations within this phony attack
received national attention for weeks
when you get the opportunity
the shooting victims and families in
this city that are victims of those
crimes give them the same amount of
attention
morgan yeah i thought the police chief
did an excellent job there but what he
did
leave out of that press conference was
the political element to this
and that's why this has gotten more
coverage than
all of the tragic murders uh that the
police chief spoke about and
so i did think it was a missed
opportunity to talk about that one thing
that we have learned is that
jesse smallett is a great actor i've
watched him on empire but he's a
terrible writer
uh when we see what he staged not only
in this attack
but in the in the letter and of course
the the resources that were diverted
one thing i would say just going back to
kamala harris
one thing to remember is there are
plenty of people who voted for
president trump in 2016 that also voted
for barack obama
so i think while it might not help her
in a primary it's important to remember
those voters and to keep those voters in
the back of her mind and to remember
that those people could still
potentially
be winnable and whenever she addresses
it fairly and shows that she's not
biased to everyone that
is supportive of trump there may be an
opening there the president
did not stay out of this some said they
thought he might but he did not uh at
jesse smallett what about magga and the
tens of millions of people you insulted
with your racist
and dangerous comments hashtag make
america great again
notably he didn't tweet about the the
coast guard
officer who was arrested by the fbi um
and his background of planning white
nationalist
killings but your thoughts in the big
picture here
matthew as we look at kind of where we
are
in this culture moment we're nowhere
good like the same people who rushed to
embrace smallett's
foe story were the people who rushed to
criticize the covington catholic boys
when that snippet of viral video came
out from the pro-life
movement uh march in dc and what was
what is the connective tissue
right it's a willingness to believe the
worst
of donald trump and his supporters and
that's why people rush to backs mullet
that's why they rush to condemn the
covington catholic boys
and now republicans sometimes are always
eager to
embrace the worst critiques of democrats
but we see time and time again
that the mainstream media amplifies the
liberal critique of republicans to far
greater extent than it does the
conservative critique of democrats
this willingness to believe narratives
no matter
their truth is very dangerous to
democracy which depends brett as we know
on evidence and patience you've seen the
president
and how he deals with twitter and
obviously he saw this moment as a
political like
hey this is the point my people are my
supporters are getting
blamed for everything to his i mean to
his defense i mean
it wasn't trump who inserted himself in
this moment it was just
small i mean he's the one who said that
the people were walking around chicago
saying
this is mega country you know lynching
people etc so
you know this was not something that
trump inserted himself
in he was explicitly inserted in the
story by
the hoaxer so i will give trump some
defense there there you go